Dave Rubin host the Rubin report we
don't agree on everything politically
but he is a sincere believer in free
speech we wanted to talk to him tonight
Dave thanks very much for coming on I'm
starting to think that a lot of us to be
with you overestimated the willingness
of the Democratic establishment to
coexist with people who disagree with
them and underestimated the real threat
the actual existential threat to speech
that we face now do you think that's
right well I wish I could say that this
whole situation is shocking but this is
exactly what I've been raising the alarm
about on my show for the last five or
seven years as you know I come from the
left I was a progressive I still
consider myself a liberal in the best
sense of liberalism classical liberalism
and I believe in the individual and all
of that stuff that we've talked about
several times but I want to I want to
address a couple things here first on
the way that you've responded to the
attacks by not apologizing I think that
was exactly the right thing to do you
know all of us have joked all of us have
made mistakes all of us have a pass all
of us have done things that were not
proud of and a series of other things if
you've lived you've done those things
including by the way the very same media
matters people who were going after you
and all the the media elite who are
relevant let me just um be there I agree
and if I have wounded someone or wronged
someone I will always apologize to that
person and ask for forgiveness I do it
every day I'm not going to apologize
absolutely matters or any other Soros
back pressure group I haven't wronged
them they've wronged me I owe them
nothing including an apology and I will
never bow to them period exactly yeah
I'm for apology but not to them well I
couldn't agree more and that's by the
way that's exactly the message that I
think your audience and the average
American needs to hear right now we have
watched years now of the mob coming for
everybody and as you just laid out a lot
of this stuff is coordinated between
nonprofits and media organizations and
the rest of it and it is time that we
stop giving in to it and not only do we
have to stop giving in to it so that a
guy like you isn't taken out and that a
network like Fox isn't taken out or or
any network you know right we are still
free here in this country for a little
while longer
and I will continue to fight for but
it's not just that it's because what
they're really trying to do is they are
trying to make the average citizen the
average person who is an American fear
that whatever they said 20 years ago
that someone can dig up on Facebook or
wherever wherever it is or some old
audio recording that they'll go after
them you were joking around with Bubba
the Love Sponge now I'm pretty sure that
as a shock jock you know who I'd love to
get involved in this fight if Howard
Stern happens to watch your show by any
chance you know for 30 years he was the
number one shock jock in the country and
imagine the politicians actors comedians
authors that walk through that studio
and said completely bananas crazy things
sometimes joking sometimes partly true
it doesn't even matter the point is that
if we are going to come for everyone's
past guess what that means everyone and
the same people who are coming for you
that they better watch out and that that
idea of mutually assured destruction
it's not in the America it's not part of
the America that I want to be part of I
want to be part of something that has a
little bit of forgiveness that
understands we're all imperfect
creatures and that is a little more
respectful of our agree our ability to
agree to disagree because that's what
this country was founded on exactly in
the last 24 hours I've received I don't
know dozens of transcripts of prominent
progressives saying awful things on this
show or that show or tax from them
you know we can do a whole show on this
they set it to I'm not doing that
because I think you ought to be able to
say what you think I think you'll be
able to make jokes make mistakes and I'm
not gonna play their game period and I
don't care if I benefit from what I'm
never doing that and very quickly tell
us you've thought about this so much and
I hope you'll come back on to further
explain it but what can the average
person who is essentially powerless in
the face of this do to protect his right
to his god-given rights start speaking
up now you know this is this comes up
every college I speak at every public
event I speak at this is what young
people are asking about I'm afraid to
speak up I want to get the grade I want
to get out of school or I don't want to
get fired from my job that that freezing
ability that is that is silencing good
decent people who usually lean a little
bit right there usually libertarians or
conservatives something like that
imagine if everyone started speaking up
and I don't believe that most people are
racist I don't believe that most people
bigots or want to do harm I think good
people are now afraid to speak and the
only way we're gonna break this thing
and that's why they're coming after you
because you've been the most vocal in
the mainstream fighting this and if more
of us start doing it they can't take us
all down and if we don't then we'll get
what we deserve which is something far
far worse than than this country that
they seem to have so many problems with
I hope your words wind up on people's
refrigerators because you're absolutely
right absolutely right Dave Rubin thank
you it's great to I'll keep defending
you man really I think more people need
to do it and you have a lot of support
out there and I can tell you this you
have support in quarters of the left
that you don't even know you do and
they're just afraid to speak out and
I'll keep working on those guys too I
appreciate it
give Rubin thank you